patrick corbin ninth career start
against the bucks
two and two with the three five three in
those first eight yeah let's see if we
can get off to a good start
two-one pitch up the middle some pace on
it
harrison turner wow
castro engineered a beauty last night
josh harrison gets a beauty started
tonight
that is a big league double play watch
trey's toe tap here to get the inning
ending double play
sweet tyler anderson four career starts
against the gnats
and the second baseman can't catch that
one tonight
adam frazier grabbed a similar liner
last night they've got kevin newman over
there tonight
and kyle schwarber is now six for his
last 14
up the middle hit well enough to get out
there hit softly enough to fall in front
of brian reynolds
and the nets haven't exactly knocked the
cover off it yet but they've got two on
for juan soto looks like another hit for
the next
the line is moving right out of the
dugout
and they're loaded with nobody out josh
harrison next
right field line ball dropped by polanco
he can't pick it up right away or he
would have had a force in second
and josh harrison puts the nats on top
just wasn't able to keep the ball
in the webbing of his glove and actually
play a little soccer
yeah that's a knock john gomez in a big
spot john gomes
deep to left c u
later five
nothing on the grand slam
400 feet fourth career grand slam
and a five to nothing lead for the
nationals
here comes another hit jordy mercer
drops one into left field
that's his 14th base it is annette
lesnar out to newman
and a 143. so corbin will bat next
dinner and that's just fine
rbi by josh harrison with bases loaded
one out then jan gomes
got under that one he knew it everybody
knew it
and now we know it's five nothing after
one
jacob stallings the catcher cleanup man
leading off for the pirates
back goes roblox way back he's at the
wall he leaves and he caught it
he caught the ball and crashed into the
fence and holds on and that hurt
into the out of town scoreboard the
screen of the lights he's up on his feet
and he gets a big hand from the crowd
paid the price to make a great play
and that is through in a hit with two
outs for eric gonzalez
keeps seeing him alive but his offense
has really
looked pretty good lately
starting to click and getting a start
against the lefty tonight
and their ball hit in the air to shallow
center field and a diving try and a
diving catch made by brian reynolds
to rob the pitcher corbin of a hit
corbin not convinced he's hanging around
first he's thinking maybe it's trapped
he's going to wait for his dugout to see
if they want to
review it challenge it they will not
it's really incredible i mean that's a
great catch by
ryan reynolds but that would have been
of the first
nine batters against tyler anderson that
would have been
the sixth weekly hit semi-line
drive drake turner's gonna fight one off
and he's two for two tonight
and trey turner has 78 hits
trey turner back over 300 now from 298
to 304
with his two base hits this evening
brings the leg up and the arm around
and a swing of the drive well hit to
right balanco playing shallow this one's
deep going back it's over his head
one hop off the wall and carbs over him
scoring his robles
turner racing for third he's in their
standing
with an rbi triple national six pirates
nothing
turner's third hit and for trey his
first triple
of the season
in there strike three call evans caught
looking at a fastball and does not like
the call the home plate umpire
corbin trying to close out his 50.
and dr corbin is in tonight he's been a
surgeon on that strike zone
four case cruising
and reynolds aboard with the two out hit
his second tonight
fairball mercer can you make the throw
yes he can jordy
mercer robs his ex-bow club of an extra
base in
that's his play of the year as annette
a little dribbler past the mound and
it'll be bare-handed but eaten
by the shortstop trey turner and gregory
polanco has a lead-off infield single
great slider one of his best of the
night
gamble like where did that one go
strikeout number five
this is in the air to shallow right
center field coming over to make a
diving try robles can't make the catch
the ball goes
all the way to the wall this will score
a run as philip evans will get an rbi
double to bring home
gregory polanco and finally the pirate
fans that are here at nats
park have a chance to cheer something
offensively
did he go ah that time he did
down goes frazier and patrick corbin is
through
seven six strack outs on the night
tonight seventh inning stretch
okay right on two
now barring a triple plate patrick
corbin will bat this in
i like his chair robles corks went out
to right center
ball tailing away it's in the gap goes
heading for third
goat's coming home into third as mercer
eminence lead seven to one as
victor robles produces rbi
number seven schwarber
lone ball right field polanco back
right in front of the bullpen two
runners tagging mercer scores
row blaze to third and then actually
eight to one
as kyle schwarber wasn't going to go a
full night without a double run better
than was
[Applause]
couple of hits here now off corbin that
might be it for
110 pitches gave me the opportunity
you got a right hander coming up that's
gonna be it
well i hope you appreciated what we've
seen here tonight
because we simply don't see starters
going to the ninth inning
that much anymore patrick corbin
was spectacular tonight
that looks like a game in depiction it
is right around
two hours and 42 minutes for patrick
corbin to pitch into the night benning
with his fourth game of the year and the
nats
outfield hugs beat the pirates to win
the series
8-1 with 13 base hits tonight